okay um
let's go for a couple of five minute
games
opponent
i went for d4
i haven't decided yet what to play um
okay let's see what he's coming up with
okay let's play nimzo for a change
queen c2 line okay
oh he's going for
for this sharp variation oh okay
of course i have no idea about this
this is supposed to be best but um i
don't know the details
so this could be
it could be difficult
yeah the problem is that this knight
is of course active but doesn't have any
squares
no idea server announcement
no idea how this is played
maybe taken knight c6
my b form to come
not sure what i actually play on
on f3
okay he decides to um just grab this
pawn
okay
so okay i'm a pawn down
but it's not um necessarily better
already
c4 is some rather weak
maybe i can get some counter play with
queen to a form
so
hmm
difficult position
not sure what he is um he should do now
on queen
d3
i also have the idea of playing b5 maybe
and then knight
before
to
to activate all the pieces
i like this idea but i'm not sure if
it's really enough
okay
let's go for this
i need to be quickly here
waste time
he most likely
will
consolidate his position
okay i think he needs to take now as
knight sees c2 with threatened
and then um
i think
knight c3
then um i was thinking maybe rook d8 or
a6
to
to open it up even more
or get some pressure on deform
difficult
a6 and i don't like a6 so much
i think maybe maybe this one first
yeah not quite sure
if this is for the pawn but
it's some compensation at least
okay
of course i can just take on deform
yeah maybe i should do that
okay
still a pawn down
but um
i'm not sure maybe this knight
can get um
can get worse
i'm not too great in development here
if i
just get one or two moves it might be
okay
get this bishop on the long
diagonal
i goes for the immediate exchange
because of the back rank here
it's a good move of course
okay
now maybe maybe 8 6 a.m
yeah i think this is the quickest way to
to get the pieces active here i cannot
play a4
okay
bishop or rook
yeah i'll try to get this rook active on
the fifth fifth rank
try rook a5
somehow
try to play against
this pawn here
yeah of course um
white is better but it's not so easy
okay to prevent something going to b5
okay
let me try get them get the king up
there
okay he wants to play king b form to
push the rook from the fifth rank
yeah of course i cannot really prevent
that
okay
check
hmm i'm not sure if this was really a
great move
if you place king c5
okay
yeah if i take now the rook end game is
certainly very
certainly bad
okay i need to play something
at least get a pawn back
of course um
this is very dangerous now i need to get
a pawn on my passport myself
as quickly as possible
it's probably lost anyway but um
check
i didn't see this one
yeah that's all wrong i can resign this
black resides yeah i didn't get enough
i didn't get enough for the pawns but
i'm still
not sure here this
shouldn't be so bad
i don't think so
maybe
and yeah rook b1 was um
was annoying
maybe we should be seven first but this
shouldn't be enough for two pawns maybe
yeah it was a difficult opening line to
face if you don't know the details